so yeah first of all I was wondering how
did you come up with the story for this
film well years ago my friend Jermaine
and I we decided that we wanted to make
a we just decide that we want to make a
vampire film we didn't know what it
would be about what kind but at there's
a very same time we both wanted to do it
and so we decided to start writing
something but there was in 2005 and once
we started we took many years to finish
it and in that time there many vampire
films came out and so we yeah I think we
kind of we had bad timing but also now
that it's coming out I think it's good
timing because it's people are so tired
of Empires movies it's like the perfect
time to have this one and did you watch
those films as well are the films and
also TV shells that came out and we're
about vampires did you um we'd I've seen
the first Twilight and that's all I know
I see the I saw the one when she had the
baby and then they're like devil baby
and then I saw I never got I never saw
True Blood
I saw underworld I underworld one and
maybe two and then I saw blade one and
three and I don't really know what else
lit the right one in which is the best
out of the last ten years and yeah not
so many but were there any things you
picked up on and which maybe also made
it in a way into your script like from
those phones I'm not really I think we
we always whenever something new would
come out we would like mention if it was
popular enough we might mention it when
we were doing about it wasn't imperative
it wasn't
very important thing for us to reference
other vampire films but like how did you
get the idea of like the twist that also
vampires are bothered by like everyday
things you know and because most vampire
films about like really powerful beings
but this one is really different or how
did you come up with that concept I
think we asked the question what do
vampires do when they're not fighting or
biting well you know it's like if
someone was to make a movie about you
know the most interesting parts of our
lives is probably you know a couple of
minutes but then what about the rest of
the time you know what else do we do
with our days what a vampires do when
they're just waiting around what do they
do when they need to do some shopping
you know how do they do laundry and what
do they do for hobbies and in their
spare time those are the kind of
questions we asked and in a nutshell
could you describe your concept of a
modern-day vampire I think a modern-day
vampire is very open and tolerant and
ready to join society and be accepted
and the problem is society doesn't
really accept vampires and I think that
the modern-day vampire also has to be
aware of things like technology changing
technology and the changing times you
know you've got to keep up with all the
stuff so that you know I think you know
like the very first iPods kind of if
they only hold like 50 songs and you
know and like for a vampire you know
it's like you can't just have the first
ipod you have to have the latest iPod
you know you've got to keep up with
everyone else so I think that's
important and also I think that the
helps I have to know about things like
recycling because when you live forever
you know you're going to see the effects
of global warming and like you know and
not recycling and
so it's really important it's like quite
a big responsibility for vampires to
recycle and if you would imagine you
yourself being a vampire
according to like your concept of
vampires and what would be for you maybe
the most annoying thing and what would
be the most enjoyable thing well the
most annoying thing about being a
vampire for me would be it would be not
having a reflection because it's you
know if you're trying to button up
something or tie your tie or like you
know just dress up you know then it's
pretty annoying if you turn up somewhere
and you know the button is wrong or the
tie is crooked so there would be the
most annoying thing for me and the best
thing the best thing would be flying and
and also having power over people and
then I was wondering how did you come up
with all of the characters in the film
because they're really different in a
way so how did you come up with it we
just tried to look at three types of
character that would have good conflict
between all three of them whilst living
in the same house and and then we also
wanted to base the three vampires on on
Dracula interview with the vampire and
the Lost Boys like those three those
three movies and then because they are
all from different time errors in the
way as well how did you and they all
have different ages and how does that
come into the movie like what difference
does it make well again I think it's
about about tolerance and learning to
accept people for who they are and you
know because Deacon who was 183 years
old to us - Vladislav and viago he's
like a kid you know he's like an
annoying kid and he's already nearly 200
you know he's yeah it's it's Ages age is
just a number it's it's how old you feel
inside and then how was it for you to
work with em Jemaine Clement because
he's also a friend of yours right you've
worked together on many projects so how
was it to come together again and to
work together again
it's always nice it's always good we've
known each other for a long time and
yeah we we always work the same way we
never you know whenever we're together
and what was the most fun about shooting
this movie and also the most difficult
then the most fun was we were shooting
with our friends so everyone in the film
alright we know you know because they
were all our friends and and dressing up
and being stupid and just hanging around
with your friends and making a movie
there's okay there's nothing more fun
than that and the most difficult
shooting in a time movie was only a
small amount of time and you know there
was rushing around and desperately
trying to get stuff but also you know it
was like a small complaint because most
of it was fun and yeah then I was also
wondering about your future plans like
what are you going to do in the future
do you already have new projects lined
up or yeah I'm writing different things
so I'm not sure which one will be next
but hopefully shoot something later in
the year and then Jemaine and I are
writing new things but I'm not shooting
anything right now but you're also doing
at the work right you're also a
photographer an artist how do you manage
to do all of these things
really managed to do those things so
much because film takes up a lot of time
but when I can you know try and keep
doing as much as I can and then for this
film you are also an actor the director
you were right and how is that to do all
these things also at the same time well
it's fun to me at first it's hard
because you know you can't see yourself
when you're doing it and you want to
make sure you're doing an okay job but
as long as you have your friends around
you to tell you if it's good or not then
yeah then it's yeah it's yeah again it's
see I wouldn't have done that if I
didn't think it will be fun if you
compare New Zealand like films from New
Zealand with for example Hollywood films
what do you think is the most different
because for example German films are
really distinctive like you can really
say they're really different to like
Hollywood films how's that difference
with New Zealand films I think New
Zealand films in general they look very
nice and sometimes they can be a little
light on story you know like it's it's
ain't often they're very serious it's
not like we don't often make comedies
you know we think Jermaine and I and a
couple of other people the only ones who
do it but I'm hoping they're more and
more people do and I'll select from the
aesthetics of movies like how they look
like the images are the differences as
well I think just the landscape you know
the way that we use a landscape a lot
because it's always there
and do you think for example like films
like the lot of rings when we still make
an impact on like the New Zealand film
scene and yeah I think the Lord of the
Rings and The Hobbit made a big impact
because it created a good industry and
like a lot of jobs so there's three it's
it's very easy to find crew members and
you know gear and equipment and stuff to
make a film it just you know as long as
you have a good story and all in all did
you enjoy being here at the Berlin Allah
and also showing your Fermi and what
were the responses so far we had a great
time being here with with the film the
audience last night was fantastic with a
really big audience and they absolutely
loved the film and you know it was one
of the best screenings we've ever had so
we were very happy